also to go back to the trans-racial
thing
people black people were
people want to be black it's like what
what does that have to do infinitely
more people have been killed for being
black than being yeah but how is that
different from just going off of his
example and him explaining race and
transgender people people have been
killed for everything so that should
that should we start being oh okay right
and then stuff is going to happen like
this like a video we're about to watch
where a teacher shows up how the teacher
shows up and it's just like oh it's okay
she's she's trans yeah and by the way
gender dysphoria absolutely exists there
are absolutely people who feel like they
are in the wrong body or feel like they
identify more with the opposite sex that
exists right I'm not I'm not questioning
that but you know there are people who
are anorexic and they're extremely
skinny and they think that they're fat
right they believe that they are fat
they have an image disorder in their
brain do you think it's a mentor the
soldier yes if yes
if you literally believe that you are
something that you're not what else do
we do we call that if I believe that I
was to use pearls an example a dog and I
might I could I could genuinely believe
that by the way have you ever have you
heard of body Integrity dysmorphia this
is a real thing body Integrity
dysmorphia is when people feel like they
should be missing a limb or they feel
like they should be disabled and to feel
whole to feel that they're true selves
they'll go and they'll amputate an arm
or amputate a leg because they feel like
their body is not they feel like they're
supposed to be disabled and they can go
and amputate a limb that that's a
disorder right that's a disorder there's
people who've intentionally blind
themselves because they identify as a
blind person and they go so far as
actually chemical objective I know you
guys see a man and a woman as an
objective thing because that's what you
were saying biologically you're either a
man or a woman I personally don't think
so okay show me show me someone who's
neither
show me that show me the person who's
not a man or a woman I mean you can go
out on the street right now and see
literally watch the next 10 000 people
walk past you can identify with 100
accuracy whether being a woman is not
about what you look like though it you
could it is you could look like a man
because maybe you're a tomboy so say a
woman yeah
exactly yeah but that's it could appear
to you as a man that's what I'm trying
to say it's not about the appearance
12 years of basketball I know some
pretty but girls you could still tell
they were girls they're still girls yeah
yeah they're still girls if you you can
look at any cell in their body it'll be
have XX chromosomes right you could look
at their skeleton you could look at
their reproductive organs
any or all of the above and that's my
point being a woman is not just about
your physical it's not just about your
biological okay what's your definition
then I can't I can't even like Define it
because you designed yourself that
someone asked you how do you know you're
a woman but I'm Different to other women
that have like that I felt maybe like a
man that felt like he was a woman and
then like transformed I'm Different to
that because me I was born as a woman
okay and I would say I how do you know
well I have a I bleed I believe like
three times do men do not three times
once you know I I think even even that
in itself that defines a woman doesn't
it as a man have you ever because a man
ever had a period in a menstrual cycle
show me one there's there's eight
billion people in the world just show me
one
I don't know it's never happened
to say something if you if you had
skipped a period for whatever reason
yeah or like you didn't have a period
for six months but you weren't pregnant
would that make you feel like a guy
because you haven't had a period
no okay I I just so it's not about
bleeding that's your you've literally
just made the point it's not about that
no it's not just about that
conceptualize a woman that's what I'm
just saying you you can an adult
human female
no I find really hard to understand is
that I'm fine I'm not gonna let I'm not
happy with anyone is trying to steal my
sex or my gender you shouldn't be right
so I would not accept I was a tomboy
growing up not once did I think I was a
man not once that I want to be a man but
I was a tomboy growing up and I
it pisses me off that people are going
to come and they're going to try and
steal my gender and they're going to try
and say that they're the same as me
I call it gender blackface I don't care
whoever they're offended I'm offended
that they want to tell me who I am yeah
we can't tell them
I am 54 years old I'm not going to get
to this age and somebody told me that
you know what makes you a woman Jennifer
that's crazy yeah
I'll be straight up I think it's
misogynistic and I don't want a man
standing next to me and he's gonna put
on a dress he's got bigger boobies than
me where he's cut his dick off as far as
I'm concerned you're not the same as me
no and it's important and you can't tell
me that I'm anything than a female I
hate all these all these other
um
different terminologies for who I am no
I'm a female birthing person I'm a woman
or is it Psy or whatever they call it I
don't know that's it and as far as well
that's what I mean because that is not
who I am I'm a female I'm a woman and if
I mean they got hermaphrodites they're
very rare yeah you know even then as far
as I'm concerned if you've got a woman
you can bleed in your hermaphrodite cut
your dick off there's no hermaphrodites
in the human species you can actually
give birth
once you've got a womb you're a woman as
far as I'm concerned they've got five as
far as you've got a womb you're a woman
as far as I'm concerned even if you've
got both and you've got a womb you can
give birth that makes you a woman so
that's the difference between a man and
a woman is that a woman has a womb if
you ain't got a womb you're not a woman
as far as I'm concerned so what about
the women that can't reproduce you
don't have a woman that's a rarity and
that's an exception and these people are
extremely women that's extreme they're
still adults we're talking about the
majority they're talking about the
majority and as far as I'm concerned no
womb no woman I feel like I feel like
you know you know what we're saying and
you know that we're right but you just
kind of like to argue a little bit not
really I think I I I have a lot of I've
been around people that have explained
how they felt and don't get me wrong
like I I don't really I wouldn't really
like my child to say oh I'm a
transgender and I I was really pissed
off when Caitlyn Jenner won a woman of
the year because that
you know what I mean like they're women
doing amazing things and you're going to
give it to a man that's just
remember he was a man and then when he
transformed into a woman then why are
you mad
it's a woman he hasn't even been a woman
for that long but he's a woman
I thought I thought you said in the
beginning that it's anyone that feels
like a woman no no but I'm saying the
fact that you won the woman yeah that's
my problem with that right but I'm
saying why would you have a problem
because there were other women that have
done a lot of things and for a long time
she's done stuff you know I mean Caitlin
Caitlyn Jenner broke records I'm sure if
it was the women's division
as a man yeah don't come in our turf
until you've done the footwork then you
can be like oh I've done this as a woman
and then you can win the woman of the
year I mean I think he's done the work
you see him recently had some surgery no
you guys no I think it's just I just
don't like people telling people what
they can be and what they can't be as
long as you're not hurting anyone
you can do what you want with you you
can do what you want you can do it
you can you can do what you want with
your body but the problem is when you
start letting people live in delusion
they start to think their delusion is
reality and so that's that's when you
see like like they're taking away titles
from women yeah and so like I'm an
athlete I played basketball for like I
don't even know anymore 15 20 years I
don't even know but like like to think
that someone could just transition and
take away a title is mad yeah and it
takes away opportunities for real women
by the way I think it's important to
note that all of the negative Downstream
repercussions of this entire cultural
psychosis only impact women
right only impact women men are not
worried about women transitioning into
men and taking their Sports record or
being in their changing rooms or being
put in they're not concerned about
females entering male prisons and so on
the same is not the true the other way
around why because the Sexes are
different and everyone knows it you may
have I don't know if you know this do
you know that there are males who are
identifying as women getting transferred
into female prisons and suddenly female
prisoners are getting pregnant how do
you think that is happening hmm let's
put this let's put this together right
and it's women who are being put at risk
from this right it's women who are
getting their records broken by
wonderful ladies such as myself
um it's women who are losing their
college scholarships for for sports who
are having men
with their penises and testicles out in
their spas in their changing rooms so on
and so forth all the negative impacts
are on women as far as I'm concerned the
people I mean it's not affected you yet
but the way things are going they will
wait until they start taking away your
rights as a woman yeah and saying there
are rights because we're women or if you
have a daughter you know and she has to
then compete and she's sporty and has to
now compete against boys and the thing
is is that I remember growing up years
ago and I didn't know there was a
I think she was a lady and her daughter
I could have been a man so many years
ago but she though she'd had the
operation and she changed I never knew
as far as I'm concerned that was just I
think it was her dad and she was a woman
before but whatever she had
transgendered into whether it's a
daughter or a man but it wasn't like oh
yes you know I'm now a man and I need
these rights and I need those rights and
I need this no it was just she just got
on with her life she didn't ask anything
of anybody she didn't try and RAM her
sexuality or her gender down people's
throats yeah as far as I'm concerned if
that's what you want to go and do go and
do it but don't tell me who I am I don't
make it affect my life yeah and don't
try and influence children society and
everybody else of it that's how you want
to be yeah but I'm the same with
everybody whether you're gay of my best
friend's gay he's gay that's his
business
but he's not going to try and rub it
down my throat or anything like that
yeah that's down to him you're allowed
to believe whatever you want to believe
whether some people think it's absurd or
not you're not allowed to force other
people to believe and accept that yeah
right this goes for absolutely
everything it goes Way Beyond this issue
this is our understanding of religious
beliefs political beliefs social beliefs
cultural belief right everyone is
allowed to believe what they want
there's billions of people in the world
we don't we don't all share the same
belief systems but if I were to come and
now try to force all the things that I
believe on someone else I can believe
that this this table is circular and
yellow I have a right to believe that I
don't have a right to try to force
everyone else in this room and everyone
else in the world to to believe and
accept and say that this table is
circular and yellow when they can see
its rectangular and black right so I
have a right I have a right to believe
that I can believe I can believe
whatever I want I can believe that I'm a
goat I can believe I'm a chicken I can
walk around on all fours and eat out of
a dog bowl if I want I can do that I
have the right to do that I can't force
everyone else to someone might be super
polite and you know pet me and treat me
like a dog or a goat or whatever you
know right if they want to but I can't I
can't force people to right if someone
is like no that's that's a man walking
around pretending to be a goat that's
not a goat right and that could hurt my
feelings if I genuinely believe I'm a
goat but if if this ever happens by the
way please like get me some help
um but just using these examples but
yeah you can believe whatever you like
but the problem with this issue and why
it's become such a contentious issue is
because it's gone far beyond people just
living their lives and doing what they
want to do it's got into an ideological
movement where they are now trying to
force people to believe and comply with
it oftentimes at the threat of
punishment someone said that why are
they not answering that question someone
said because they'll get fired right
that's coercion right if you are not
allowed to say something that is
factually correct and true because
you're worried about losing your job
you're not in a good as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible